So this really has to be seen to be believed
Donald Trump and Trump ists are now increasingly
furious with Fox News, I guess, because Fox
admits that Joe Biden won, for example.
And a FOX News also cut away from a press
conference yesterday with Trump's press secretary,
Kayleigh McEnany, because she was lying in.
Neil Cavuto said, whoa, whoa, whoa.
If she presents some evidence for these claims
will go back to it.
But these are really serious allegations to
be making about voter fraud.
So the point is Trump now and many Trump ists
are furious with Fox News and Trump has doubled
down and humiliated himself even more, if
you can imagine, by starting to tweet out
clips of Newsmax.
Now, if you haven't heard of Newsmax, good
for you.
First of all, Newsmax is sort of similar to
OMON in some way.
It's like a low budget version of Fox News.
Some people say it looks kind of like a porn
parody of Fox News.
They have massive integrity issues.
They emailed their subscriber list during
the pandemic saying the worst thing you could
do is get a vaccine because vaccines are one
of the biggest scams among the American people.
So you sort of get the idea of where Newsmax
is.
Trump now, I guess because he's furious with
Fox News regularly, is tweeting out Newsmax
clips and you have to see it to believe it.
They've set up interviews where it's not even
clear that the anchor understands the questions.
They almost look like infomercials, where
the anchor is sort of like, tell me all the
ways in which this was stolen from Donald
Trump.
And then they just give some mouthpiece on,
you know, uninterrupted time to just say,
tell lies.
Here's one with an RNC spoke spokesperson
on fraud claims.
What can we expect to see in court?
We will pursue every legal avenue because
what's going on right now is a total travesty.
This is not the United States of America where
we have free and fair elections with legal
votes cast.
And that's what who decides elections, not
media organizations.
Now, I'm not going to play long clips.
There's a lot more to this, but my suspicion
is that exposure to too much of this drivel
probably is bad for your health.
I don't want to do that to the audience, so
I'm going to keep the clips pretty short.
Here's another one with actually, this is
with Congressman Jody Hice.
I'll talk to you about Jody Hice in a moment.
But this was around the time Trump tweeted
he's going to win Georgia yesterday.
I don't mean on Election Day yesterday, Trump
tweeted he's going to win Georgia.
And here is Congressman Jody Hice claiming
the same thing because of either reporting
or recording or who even knows what.
Take a look.
It's very close and quite frankly, I believe
it's on the verge of getting a lot closer.
Fulton County just came out just within the
last hour or so recognizing that they have
a significant issue on reporting that they
did on Friday.
Zio, the NBC television affiliate, is already
saying that this is significantly going to
change the count in favor of President Trump.
At the same time, Gwinnett County has come
out in the last hour or so indicating that
they likewise have some glitches.
Now that congressman there, Jody Hice, he's
a disgusting guy.
Back in it was 2014.
He claimed that there was a gay plot to sodomized
your children and also in 2014 said his belief
is that women need their husband's permission
to enter politics.
That's Jody Hice who was interviewed on Newsmax
and then signal boosted by Donald Trump.
And then here is Trump flunky Richard Grenell.
You might remember Richard Grenell from the
RNC.
He actually spoke at the RNC, just claiming
it's all fraud.
Like it's just the entire thing is fraudulent.
Every single one of these videos I've played
for you so far has been flagged by Twitter
as disinformation about an election.
Take a look at those that are now coming back
to haunt us ballots that were mailed out of
state, people saying I haven't lived in Nevada
for years.
We saw more than three thousand people who
lived out of state get ballots.
We brought those to the authorities attention.
Many of those people have broken the residency
requirements and this is just the tip of the
iceberg.
So whatever the outcome of the election is
when it's certified, and that is not certified
yet and we still have tens of thousands of
votes yet to be counted, just absolute, complete
and total nonsense.
And it really like it's almost getting sad
in more ways than we imagined.
And if you are the president and.
All you have left is Newsmax clips to try
to make it look like there are people who
agree with you, just pack it up, go and play
golf the rest of your term.
Joe Biden has already launched a coronavirus
task force just announced you're turning over
management of the virus to Joe Biden, the
incoming the elect administration.
Just go.
And I believe it was Trump's former personal
attorney, Michael Cohen, who said yesterday
in an interview he expects that at Christmas
time, Trump will leave and go to his resort
in Florida or somewhere and that he won't
even come back to the White House.
I think that's possible.
Trump actually doing things as president may
be over as we know it.
There's nothing on his schedule.
There hasn't been anything on his schedule
on any day since the election.
This may change, but Trump really may just
be done and he will just tweet about how he
really won and then quietly disappear around
Christmastime.
We don't yet know.
But it's getting really, really embarrassing
unless unless unless.
And this is very important.
Unless Trump restarts his MAGGA rallies and
there is a report claiming he plans to do
that, and I want to talk about that now